Такі натовпи людей 10 років тому не можна було б уявити.
Ісландія була майже банкрутом.
Як цей острів так швидко оговтався від кризи?
DW вирушила до Ісландії, щоб це з'ясувати.
У 2008-му навряд чи багато хто чув про цю безплідну землю.
Нині ж це одна з найбільш популярних країн для туризму.
На цілому острові проживає лише 350 тисяч мешканців.
Це у 12 разів менше, ніж у Києві.
У 2008-му році ми мали банківську кризу.
Я добре це пам'ятаю, це було у жовтні.
Люди були спустошені, і вони дуже боялися, тому що не знали, яким буде майбутнє.
Але я думаю, що туризм - це справді чудова можливість для людей в Ісландії,
особливо, щоб отримати кращі робочі місця.
Я знаю багато людей, які працюють у туризмі, а також багато друзів навколо мене.
Ця мальовнича природа вабить туристів.
Але причиною економічного буму стала також національна валюта - крона.
Через кризу ісландська валюта впала, і це значить, що експорт став набагато дешевшим,
а Ісландія стала набагато доступнішою для туристів.
Експорт з Ісландії - це, насамперед, риба.
Криза була катастрофою для всіх ісландців, але не для експортерів риби.
А в Ісландії їх багато.
Вони змогли продавати свою продукцію значно дешевше за кордон.
Стейнгрімюр Лейфссон - один з них.
Він показує свою фабрику під Рейк'явіком.
Я виріс у маленькому рибальському селищі в Ісландії.
Там все залежить від риби.
Бізнес для нас і для всіх інших рибних компаній був дуже вдалим після кризи.
Ми майже вдвічі збільшили продажі.
У Рейк'явіку економічне піднесення не можна не помітити.
Скрізь будівельні майданчики.
Навіть там, де колись була стара Ісландія - банки.
Нині замість них будують готелі.
Асдіс Крістьянсдоттір у 2008-му працювала у найбільшому ісландському банку Kaupthing.
Цю вулицю називали Уолл-Стріт Ісландії.
Принаймні до кризи. За кілька метрів був Kaupthing Bank.
Сьогодні це вже Arionbanki.
Нині Асдіс представляє Асоціацію ісландських підприємств.
90 відсотків нашої банківської системи обвалилися за лічені дні.
Але сьогодні нам вдалося створити зовсім нову банківську систему, яка є дуже міцною.
Я не думаю, що хто-небудь міг би уявити, наскільки стабільні ми сьогодні.
Неймовірно, як швидко економіка відновилася.
Але цей неймовірний бум також має і негативний бік.
Ісландія останнім часом стає дедалі дорожчою для туристів.
Невеличка риба з картоплею фрі коштує 25 євро.
Це одна з причин того, чому бум у туризмі сповільнився,
особливо зараз, коли з'являється дедалі більше нових готелів.
Тим не менше відновлення Ісландії після фінансової кризи - унікальне.
Це справді особливий острів зі своїм економічним дивом.